hey stranger nothing so what are you
doing it we disappeared on us thought
about Monty's offer yet yeah you can't
come in here talking about that light
I'm uh working yeah you seem super busy
yeah well these babies don't punish
themselves all right so are you in or
out I can't it's too dangerous
oh come on miles don't be a [ __ ] you
can do this really not that hard right I
really appreciate the pep talk but ain't
happening
it's just a couple of pills from Monty's
friend at some lab so we can figure out
what's in it and make his own all you
got to do is bring them back it'll be
easy plus it's a free trip to Mexico
what more do you want all right so I'll
be like a little drug me on perfect I'll
write you a thank you note from prison
okay
I'm you know what 20 grand that's your
business
20 grand before you say there's 10 yeah
it was it's 20 now so real
for real hmm oh and you can bring guitar
shop Barbie with you
medical marijuana is already a
multi-billion dollar industry the future
is this weed pill I'm still not sure
about this look most people will tell
you Buzz Aldrin walked on the amendment
but even a complete idiot will tell you
Neil Armstrong did it first and do you
know why he went first dishes hatch open
and hiss because you push bezel and the
[ __ ] out of the way and seize history by
the ball sack I'm satisfied
[Laughter]
look man you're in some deep water
Harold like bankruptcy dude then cash
pool no I'm saying you're poor poor
tomorrow you're gonna fly to Mexico what
we want you to hand-deliver the weed
pill formula to the lab and I'm not
supposed to touch the minibar but I'm
going to do it you know I don't even
care anymore I'm doing it I'm having the
moon
[Music]
what a [ __ ] cry-baby
Harold I'm just gonna spit this out
gonna Fifi I sold a little product to
the cartels but when we cut them off
they got a little angry
I know a guy
I've tracked down dictators if I can
find a guy in middle man what do they
want
injected a microchip I need to keep
track II can't scare me the tales of the
big bad cartels know things work not in
Mexico that's Harold Harold didn't go
Gala Bingo
you really believe in God of course I
believe in God what kind of person does
not believe in God I guess I kind of do
but not things you can just have to get
better for you trust me
I have good instincts
you